[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So welcome to Google.
I'm so excited to have you here.
And for those of us
who have seen the film,
this is a really--
a remarkably fresh
and modern film.
It's a modern take on that
classic high school story.
So I really want to
commend all of you
for putting together something
really relatable and yet
incredibly unique.
So we're really excited
to be chatting about it.
I wanted to start
with you, Olivia.
I know that this is
your directorial debut.
This is a first film
that you have been
sitting in the director's seat.
Is that right?
OLIVIA WILDE: Yes.
True.
SPEAKER 1: So I recognize that
this is somewhat of a cliche
question to start out with.
But I think a lot of us who have
seen you on screen and in film
were curious about what
that transition looked like
and how it felt actually
being in that director's seat.
So could you tell us
a little bit about it?
OLIVIA WILDE: Yes.
First of all, this is very cool.
We're freaking out.
We're very, very excited.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's really interesting.
I think the film industry is
unique in its kind of fluidity
within the roles
of the industry.
You are allowed and in
some ways encouraged
to take on different roles, from
actor to producer to director.
And I think that's
something that's
kind of great about the
way the industry works.
Where there is a
will, there is a way.
You are able to kind of move
fluidly between those roles.
So I'd been producing
for several years.
And I'd directed short
films and music videos
and really learned
a lot doing that.
But when I really wanted to
leap into the feature space
as a director, I found
that the barriers
weren't impossible to overcome.
They were challenging.
It is a matter of
proving oneself as--
stepping out of
what people know you
as, even within the industry.
But I was kind of really
pleasantly surprised
by the willingness to accept
the idea, the concept of hey,
I'm actually going to take the
reins and be in charge now.
And particularly
from the actors,
it's really an honor when
actors, fellow actors,
agree to be in your film
and to allow themselves
to be directed by you.
It's a really amazing
experience and to say, listen,
I speak your language.
I respect what you do.
I can empathize completely.
And now, I want to work with
you in this different way.
I want to take charge.
Will you go on this
journey with me?
So I was just kind of
overwhelmed with gratitude
at every moment.
I was like, I can't
believe everybody
is gathering for me to tell this
weird story that's in my head.
And some of the particularly
weird moments that I was--
like when I asked them
to do a stop motion
Barbie sequence
where they would be
miniaturized into Barbies after
they take drugs by accident.
And everybody was like,
yeah great, no problem,
going to love doing that.
So I will say, the transition
was really exciting.
It took me a long time to
build that courage, though.
I'm 35.
I've been wanting to
direct since I was 23,
so it took some time.
I started doing shorts when
I was like 26 and then music
videos from there.
But I'm really, really
happy to be here.
And now, I'm hooked, and it's
all I ever want to do forever.
SPEAKER 1: That's amazing.
Yeah, 35.
Super unaccomplished at 35.
[LAUGHTER]
Making all of us in
our 30s feel bad.
No, that's great.
So for all of you
actually, what was it
that drew you to this project?
I know, Katie, you did a
lot of work in the writing
and producing and helping
to shape some of the story.
And for each of you
who are in the film,
I don't want to
do a round robin.
But for anyone who would
like to answer, what was it
about this film
that drew you in?
KATIE SILBERMAN:
I think for me--
just because I got
to join first--
well, besides
Kaitlyn, actually--
it was the opportunity to tell
the kind of generational anthem
that Olivia was excited
to tell, like when
we talked about our favorite
movies and the movies that
made us want to make movies.
It was stuff like "Fast Times
at Ridgemont High" and "Dazed
and Confused" and "Clueless" and
"Mean Girls" and these movies
that not only were funny
enough and joyful enough
that you could re-watch
them all the time,
but that also were very timely
in terms of the generation they
depicted.
They're so specific
about what it
was like to be a
teenager at that time,
and at the same
time, really timeless
in just telling
wonderful stories
about what it's like to be
young and friends and in love.
And so I have always wanted
to make a high school
movie like that, because I
think everyone's emotions are so
heightened.
Everyone's selves are so
heightened in high school.
And it's a really
wonderful opportunity
to tell a story that's
so concentrated that way.
But I would also say,
the biggest thing
was wanting to work with
Olivia in hearing her vision.
Hi.
She had such a clear vision,
a contagiously exciting vision
and tone for the movie
she was going to make.
And I've said before, I
wanted to watch that movie,
let alone be a part of it.
And so getting to speak to
her about what she was going
to do and see immediately how
extraordinary it was going
to be and how talented she was
and how fun it was going to be,
that was probably the
biggest motivator.
SPEAKER 1: Well, it really is.
It's such a unique take
on the high school story.
And so for Kaitlyn, for
Beanie, for both of you being
in the space, there were--
and actually for
the entire group,
there were so many moments
where you could recognize
that the film
could have slipped,
if it had been a different
film, into some of the tropes
that we see just repeated and
repeated in high school films.
And it really managed to avoid
falling into those tropes
over and over again.
So Kaitlyn, for your character,
Amy, to be in the space,
I think--
this is a slightly
selfish question
and for our LGBTQ
folks in the audience--
but I was not out in high
school, and coming out
was a much more
challenging process.
And I think there was a
lot of self-justification
that a lot of us need to
do to exist in the world
and be normal members
of broader society.
And one of the incredibly
unique pieces of this film,
very personally, was that
the fact that Amy was queer--
I don't know how Amy
identified, but identified
as queer of some stripe--
was a non-issue.
It did not inspire struggle.
It was not something that
other people struggled with.
It wasn't a point of
contention in the film.
It was just simply a
piece of her identity,
and that was so refreshing
for a lot of us.
So I'm curious, is
that a reflection
of where you see a
younger generation moving?
And do you think that
that is something
that was a good reflection
of high school in general
at the moment, since it's been
a few years for some of us?
KAITLYN DEVER: I
feel like, well,
the thing about '"Booksmart"--
the one thing that
attracted me to this script
when I first read it was Amy
and how much I would have--
when I first read her, I'm like,
oh my god, I have to play her.
And I think "Booksmart"
does so beautifully
represent the generation that
I am currently living in.
I think that I feel so honored
to play a girl like Amy,
and I feel like it's so
beautiful that it wouldn't
be in her character bio.
It wouldn't say,
Amy, 18, is queer.
It wouldn't say that.
I think in the beginning
stages of developing her,
I don't even think we really
talked about it, because we
didn't want to make it a thing.
In coming-of-age movies, you
do see the coming out scene,
normally.
And I love how it just--
we don't need that in the movie.
Actually, the coming out scene
is when Molly's character
is telling me she--
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: Crushing
on this one back here.
KAITLYN DEVER: Crushing
on the jock of the movie.
And I just think
it's so beautiful,
and I feel so honored
to be able to play her.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: I also
love that the film depicts
a platonic but deeply, deeply
loving relationship between two
women that is so
beautiful and unique
and celebrated in its beauty.
But then one of the
characters happens to be queer
and how that love is never--
it's just, it's celebrated
in a different way
than romantic love.
And I love that our film
gives that treatment
to a friendship that involves
one heterosexual girl and one
queer girl.
And I just feel like
I've never really seen
that much of that,
especially in such
a young space like high school.
And I was really
moved by that as well.
SPEAKER 1: You took the next
question right out of my mouth.
I love that.
She's psychic.
So on that note, for your
two characters, really--
I mean, the bond
feels very genuine.
Did you know each other
before coming into this film,
or is that something
you developed
while you were making it?
KAITLYN DEVER: Well, we realized
that we had passed each other
in the world, just
like we'd constantly
been passing each other
but never actually got
to have a full embrace.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: That's the
girl from "Short Term 12".
Oh my god, she's so talented.
KAITLYN DEVER: And
then we finally met
when we both were finally
attached to "Booksmart."
And we were like, eek.
We just met at lunch
one day, and we
couldn't contain ourselves.
And we were pretty much
holding hands the whole time,
like we were engaged.
And it was instantaneous.
It's so easy to love
Beanie Feldstein.
And then we were talking about
the movie, talking about prep.
And then we still can't
figure it out, but one of us
mentioned it.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: I
think it was Olivia.
KAITLYN DEVER: I
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: It was
the three of us at lunch.
And Liv was like, I mean,
you could live together.
And Kaitlyn and I were
like, can we do that?
Is that allowed in the world?
But when you go on
location to film a movie,
there's this inherent
bond that you get,
because you don't
really know anyone
else other than each other.
So you spend all
your time together.
But we were filming
the movie in LA.
And Kaitlyn lives in
LA, and I'm from LA.
So we knew that it wouldn't be
the same as being tucked away
in this small town where you
don't really know anyone.
But we wanted to replicate
that experience, because it's
so helpful and so
deeply meaningful
when you just feel genuinely
comfortable and trusting
and genuinely love
the person that you're
looking at all day, every day.
And so living
together just gave us
this beautiful, relaxed
foundation of a friendship,
so that when we layered
Molly and Amy on top of it,
it felt so easy and so seamless.
KAITLYN DEVER: It also
felt like we were just
living in our own
world for two months,
because we'd go to work
from 6:00 PM to 6:00 AM,
go home and sleep and then
have pancakes together, go over
lines and then go back to work.
And we were just on
our own time zone,
and we were spending,
literally, 24/7 with each other.
SPEAKER 1: That's pretty
intense after a little while.
So Mason, for you,
coming in again,
I just come back to this idea
of not playing on these tropes.
We had the good
looking, popular guy.
But there are lots of
layers to that character.
[LAUGHTER]
MASON GOODING: I
mean, if you say so.
SPEAKER 1: I mean, yeah.
Queer girls can say that, too.
It's cool.
MASON GOODING: Of course.
SPEAKER 1: So how was it
developing that character?
And was the character of
Nick analogous in any way
to your high school experience?
MASON GOODING: So no.
I was probably the dorkiest you
could get in high school, which
is good because I feel like that
builds character and can allow
you to see from
within and without.
Nick is an
interesting character,
because I love the way
it was written as--
especially at first-- very
jock and stereotypical,
in that sense, where he just
exudes cool and sort of pushes
from within, like, oh, if
you're not quite in this circle,
you maybe can't hang out.
And as it speaks to the rest
of the people in this film--
I mean, Nico's a
phenomenal actor as well as
being a great skater.
Kaitlyn sings like you
wouldn't believe in addition
to being a phenomenal actor.
And Nick has this side
to him where just being--
[LAUGHTER]
BEANIE FELDSTEIN:
All right, Mason,
remember our dance number?
MASON GOODING: I was going to
get to that if you would just
give me two seconds.
That Beanie is a phenomenal--
I mean, she's so good at
everything in addition to just
being a phenomenal person.
No, again, it all ties into
the fact that we're all--
OLIVIA WILDE:
Let's all go around
and say what we love
about Beanie Feldstein.
MASON GOODING: We might as well.
He sort of brings people
in just to be excited
and to be happy in themselves,
and it comes out even
in Molly's fantasy ideal of him,
that they're dancing together.
And they can do this thing
where you can showcase Beanie's
phenomenal dancing skills.
OLIVIA WILDE: They are amazing.
MASON GOODING: They
really, really are.
And it was just such a joy to
be able to bring that to light,
because everybody is someone
different on the inside
than you might be able
to get from first glance.
So it's really a good idea
to give people that time to--
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: I love
the moment at the party.
I love the dance sequence.
And Mason had never
danced once in his life.
Isn't that remarkable?
MASON GOODING: Not once.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: And
also to be partnering,
it takes so much
trust and dedication.
And I was just in awe of him.
MASON GOODING: You
make it so easy.
KAITLYN DEVER:
You're so incredible.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN:
But I love the film.
I love the moment in
the film at the party
when you just see everything
Molly had projected onto Nick,
like she's really mean about him
at the beginning of the film.
She's like, oh god, why do
I have to deal with him?
Why?
Obviously, harboring
something underneath.
But I think the
moment where he's just
like, I can't believe Molly
showed up at the party.
And I think what the film does
so beautifully is, it takes--
specifically through
my character's judgment
of people--
it takes that archetype that
you're projecting onto them
and completely flips
it on its head.
And I always say, the fact that
there's two smart girls, two,
three, four, five cool skater
kids, two rich, party kids--
the fact that there's
two of every archetype
that we've set out for what
high school looks like,
it inherently breaks
down that concept.
And the ideology just
kind of crumbles.
Because if you have
more than one smart girl
and they're interested
in different things
and they're completely
different human beings,
then the concept of what a
smart girl is ceases to exist.
And it just becomes complicated,
multi-dimensional humans.
And I think Nick is such a
beautiful example of that
in the film, because she
projects so much judgment
onto him and then, obviously,
is pleasantly surprised
and then devastated.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Nico, I would
say the same thing, also,
for your character,
Tanner, that, really, I
think through the film
you're searching for--
and I hate that
we've been socialized
into doing this
when we watch films,
but you're searching for
where to place that character.
So what was it like for you
bringing that person to life,
who was also deeply
multi-dimensional
and could have been the
offbeat, maybe artsy kid, also
possibly a skater,
but also super smart
and headed off to
Stanford in the fall.
NICO HIRAGA: Tanner
was just basically
the tie between
the skater group--
Victoria, who played
Ryan, and the jock group,
which is Eduardo and Mason.
And he was just kind
of a lonely dude
there, just kind of cruising
around on his four wheels,
just going about.
But he was just kind of like
the tie between the two groups.
And it was really
cool to play Tanner,
because I could relate
to a lot of the things--
that I experienced in
high school at least--
the same as him.
It was rad.
SPEAKER 1: Do you
want to share any
of those high school experiences
that are analogous to Tanner?
You don't have to-- didn't
mean to put you on the spot.
MASON GOODING: PG
version, please.
NICO HIRAGA: Academically,
he cared more about sports
than he did in academics.
And I'd say that was
true in high school.
I did play soccer
in high school.
And I didn't make it to
Stanford, but Tanner did.
[LAUGHTER]
It's all good.
SPEAKER 1: So this
film really feels
like it comes together
pretty seamlessly,
and you've done something
really extraordinary by creating
all of these multi-dimensional
characters that
are in this particularly
stereotypical stage
in their life.
So what challenges
did you encounter when
you were coming across this?
I'd say, particularly,
Katie and Olivia,
as you were going
through this process,
there are thousands
upon thousands
of scripts that are written
that could be easily followed.
But taking it outside
of the box, I imagine,
would sometimes be
difficult as you're
trying to put those
characters together.
So what was that
process like, and what
challenges do you come across?
OLIVIA WILDE: Well,
I mean, the reason
that Katie was the ideal
screenwriter to come on board
and reshape and re-imagine
this existing material
was because she had these
incredibly specific and smart
ideas of how to
expand each character
and how to expand the
general narrative.
I had pitched on
this movie because I
loved the concept of two very
smart women who love each other
and aren't trying to
assimilate to become
the cool kids or
the popular kids.
They think they are cool.
They're kind of gangster
about their intelligence,
and I loved that.
But I knew that we
could kind of break up
open the rest of the film
and say something bigger.
And when I met Katie and
I heard her take on it,
I was so inspired, because she
saw exactly what you're seeing.
She saw the way to
break it out of the box,
make everything more nuanced and
just deeply much, much funnier
and smarter.
And I was like,
this is exciting,
because we knew we
had the opportunity
to make something
different and to take
something people
thought they understood
and to kind of flip
it on its back.
But I was really amazed at the
speed and the skill of Katie
as she kind of reshaped
the entire thing.
KATIE SILBERMAN: Thank you.
One thing that's really
fun, that you kind of hit on
before too, though, is I
think movies and high school
are probably the
two areas in life
where archetypes
are the most used
and you can jump to easily.
So the boxes that you put
people to in high school--
the same way you're
searching for characters,
like as moviegoers, you're
just as likely as the audience
to try and say like, oh,
that's the hot guy, that's
the mean girl, that's
the dorky girl.
And so we got to play into
those archetypes on both levels,
both the archetypes that
Molly and Amy were projecting
onto all of their classmates
and the archetypes
that the audience would so
easily project onto the people
that they were seeing on screen.
And the dream for us
from the beginning
was to create a world
and an ensemble where
any of the characters, you
would be happy if we just
turned and followed them--
you would watch a whole
movie about all of them,
which is, I think, sometimes
in movies, what you forget
to do-- like forget to create
a world that's full enough
that you would be interested
in following all of them
throughout the rest of
their nights as well.
So that was a fun challenge
to set up, because that's
what high school is like.
Also, there are all these people
you see in a classroom and only
defined by the way they
interact on the school building
and seeing them outside-- like
if you ever run into someone
from school at like a--
I was going to say a
Blockbuster, which is--
[LAUGHTER]
Or like waiting for the
horse and carriage to come.
[LAUGHTER]
But when you see
people that you only
knew in school outside of
school with their families
or with their friends, it was
so startling to be like, oh,
you have this whole
world outside of here
that I don't know and so
being able to peel back
throughout the night
everyone else at school
was probably the
most fun challenge.
SPEAKER 1: I hope that
you're contemplating
spin-offs, single films for
each of these characters
as well as they go through.
We want to see, obviously, Amy
off in Botswana, definitely
Tanner at Stanford.
NICO HIRAGA: Stanford.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
So I'm actually curious
while folks line up--
I'm curious what the
origin of this film was.
Who originated that first
seedling of an idea?
Where did that come from?
KATIE SILBERMAN:
The original script
was written in 2009,
so 10 years ago,
by two really talented writers,
Emily Halpern and Sarah
Haskins.
And it's been around
in different iterations
in that decade, the core idea
being a story about two really
smart best friends
in high school.
And I think the story kind
of evolved and changed
with different people attached
at different times in ways
to kind of reflect what it was
like in these different time
periods as well, even
the change for what
it was like for young women
in 2009 to 2012 to 2015.
I think there's been a
desire for a kind of movie
like this for a long time.
And then I felt really
lucky that when I came on
and Olivia was attached and
had this unbelievable vision
and just energy towards it,
that we were able to say,
what is the movie we
want to make right now?
And what's the high
school movie we feel
like we've never seen before?
OLIVIA WILDE: It's
almost like the society
had to catch up with the
concept before it could be made.
SPEAKER 1: It feels very much
that way when you watch it.
And clearly, it was very
impressive after taking
10 years to actually
make the film.
And for you, being
your first time,
it was a very
impressive first try.
OLIVIA WILDE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: At Google, we
like to say, fail fast,
and we're all very
familiar with this concept
of failing on the first try.
You just skipped over that part.
A 100% rating on Rotten
Tomatoes for your first one
ain't so bad.
Clap for that.
[APPLAUSE]
Should we go to audience Q&A?
AUDIENCE: So I have
a two part question.
One is for the
group, which is, what
was the most challenging
part of making the movie?
And then the second part
is specifically for Olivia.
You talked about getting to
35 to make that transition,
to something that you'd
wanted to do at 23.
And I think all of us have
dreams and inspirations
that we're trying to
get to or that we're at,
and just any advice
you can give in terms
of getting over that barrier
and what that looks like.
OLIVIA WILDE: Sure.
Well, I'll take that one first,
because it's fresh in my mind.
It makes me think
of my mom, actually.
My mom ran for Congress
last year in Virginia.
And it was incredibly inspiring,
because it was a pivot for her
at 66 years old.
She'd been a journalist for
35 years, top of her game
journalist, produced "60
Minutes" for 10 years,
"Frontline," "ABC News."
You name it, she made it.
And seeing her decide, actually,
after the 2016 election,
that she needed to--
she said, the real resistance
is running for office.
And I have an incredible
amount of respect for her.
So watching her pivot at that
point in life was incredible.
It happened to be the same
exact moment I was pivoting.
So we were in these parallel
tracks of reinvention.
And we talked a lot about what
that process is like and how
really what it is giving
yourself permission
and understanding that you're
worthy of that reinvention,
and that you--
much like we were just
speaking of in this film,
a lot of the kind of barriers
we create are self-generated.
A lot of what keeps us in a
place of acting out of fear
is just self-generated.
And if you give yourself
permission to do
whatever it is you
want to do, no matter
how far it is from what
you're currently doing--
it's amazing when you
realize, oh really,
no one else was stopping me?
That was just me, huh?
I wish I had done
that a long time ago.
But I think it's
something that's
kind of incredible about
being a human being.
And I think so often we choose
a track at 19 years old.
You go to college, and you're
like, this is my major.
Or maybe after college,
you're like, well,
that's what I studied, and
now I'm picking my career.
And you really
trust a 24-year-old
to make a decision that
should last for a lifetime?
No.
I think what stops us
sometimes from pivoting
is this fear that it will seem
like it somehow devalues what
we did before, that
it somehow implies
a hypocrisy of some
type, that oh, it
means that this wasn't real.
A lot of people have been
asking me, so no more acting?
I guess that wasn't your thing.
And I'm like, you know
what, I love acting.
It's catharsis.
It's therapy.
It's the most fun
thing in the world.
It is something I hope
to do as well as this.
Why do we have to choose?
I've been thinking
so much about it.
We make these choices, and we
put this pressure on ourselves.
Why?
We get one life.
We should try everything.
And I think for me, the fear was
like, well, I've chosen acting,
and I didn't go to film school.
So I guess this is my track and
then realized, no way, there
are plenty of inspiring
examples of people
who have made that leap.
And I really want to go for it.
Also, getting rid of the fear
of failure, I love fail fast.
The idea that just,
go for it, truly
what's the worst
thing that can happen?
You don't want to die
regretting that you didn't try.
So that's my take on that.
And then in terms of what
was most challenging,
I'll throw that to you
guys, because I just
had fun everyday.
And nothing was hard.
[LAUGHTER]
KAITLYN DEVER: I almost started
crying during that answer.
You made me believe in myself.
I feel like everything
that Beanie and I
thought was going to
be a challenge ended up
not being one.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: First
I was like, Mandarin?
OK.
And then it ended
up being so fun.
KAITLYN DEVER: Yes, so fun.
It was very easy.
I think also when we
first sat down with Liv,
she really wanted to stick to
the no sides on set rule, which
is--
usually on sets, I'll usually
have my lines in rehearsal,
and everyone's looking at them.
And it's sort of distracting.
And we were like, oh
boy, we're talking
the whole time in the movie,
and how are we going to do that?
And it was super easy.
It was great.
And then the 26 day shoot
also seemed daunting
but then it all--
I don't know.
I don't think anything
was really challenging.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN:
I think for me,
the scariest thing was Molly
herself really scared me.
I think in the few things I've
been lucky enough to be in,
I have always played a very
endearing, sweet person,
and that is who I
like to project myself
into the world as.
And I loved Molly.
But I was also so intimidated
by her, because at first glance,
she's not that at all.
And she's really intense
and unapologetically so.
And I think that scared me.
It took a lot of bravery to
not hold back and not say,
well, she's not being kind,
and she's not nice right now.
And that's kind of hard.
And that's just not who she is.
She leads with her intellect.
She leads with her passion, and
she leads with her love of Amy.
But other than that, she doesn't
care about being pleasant,
and that was really scary
and then, ultimately,
really inspiring to me.
MASON GOODING: It's just
so funny, because when
people say the hardest part--
an easy answer would be,
four weeks of night shoots
is hard for sure.
But it never once
genuinely felt like I
was pushing myself to do
something I felt I had to do.
That was part of an atmosphere
that was built on set.
It's part of having a great
cast to support you and push you
to be your best, inherently.
And every day on
set was a treat,
and it felt like I came to
do exactly what I loved.
I'm sure I speak for all of us
when it felt like every time
we showed up on set,
you could see everyone
was excited to be there.
Everyone was bringing their
A game, that it was like,
oh, wait, this is--
we're making something
that can ultimately
touch a whole bunch of people.
I'm going to do my
best, regardless.
So hard is funny.
Sure, things were difficult
in terms of [? diamond ?]
but it all was a dream.
KATIE SILBERMAN:
I honestly think
the hardest part was the
deep depression that set in
as it started to be over.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: She
says that she got married
our last week of production.
KATIE SILBERMAN: That's true.
KAITLYN DEVER: I don't
want to go to my wedding.
I want to be with you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
KATIE SILBERMAN: Conner, hi.
KAITLYN DEVER: We love
you, Conner, hello.
NICO HIRAGA: I was completely
agreeing with Katie.
The hardest part was being
like, oh, the movie's over.
We're done filming.
That was for sure the hardest
part of the whole process.
Other than that, it would be
like hitting the Snooze button
on your phone when your alarm
goes off in the morning.
That was hard.
But other than
that, everything--
solid.
SPEAKER 1: It sounds like
during the course of this film,
you really built it
up into a family,
and I am sure that
spending that much time--
we know.
We're working on teams.
We're doing sprints.
You're spending hours
and days [INAUDIBLE]..
My poor colleague, Anthony, will
know what I'm talking about,
because he has to spend
every day with me.
But sometimes, you develop a
really strong sense of family,
and sometimes you don't.
So did you have methods for
building a sense of trust
in between you as
individuals in order
to help benefit that bond that
actually came out in the film?
Did you have tactics, or was it
simply spending time together
that got you all that close?
NICO HIRAGA: Olivia
was a mommy figure
during this whole filming.
Mason, Eduardo, and I,
we all had playdates
throughout the whole film.
[LAUGHTER]
MASON GOODING: We
filmed them, too.
NICO HIRAGA: It's on film.
MASON GOODING: You'll see
them at some point, I'm sure.
SPEAKER 1: Amazing,
please send those clips.
MASON GOODING: Of course,
to you specifically.
OLIVIA WILDE: There's
one where an orange was
sliced with a machete.
MASON GOODING: Yeah, it
was a full knight's sword.
OLIVIA WILDE: Slow motion,
a knight's sword slicing.
MASON GOODING: Yeah, I have
a replica "Game of Thrones"
sword.
I told you, I was a big
dark in high school.
And we found a
bunch of oranges--
SPEAKER 1: You're in very
good company, by the way.
MASON GOODING: Well,
good, Season 8, right?
And we were just throwing
them at each other,
and we would slice
them with the sword.
OLIVIA WILDE: This makes me
think of something that's
really singular
about this cast, is
that I asked them to
do quite a lot outside
of the official working hours.
I knew that in order
for this to work,
it would be made or
broken by their chemistry.
So I asked them to hang out.
They could have said, listen
lady, I'll show up on the days
I'm working, but you can't tell
me what to do on the weekends.
And instead, everybody
was so inspired.
Before we started
filming, we all
gathered to watch "Fast
Times at Ridgemont High."
And the reason I
really wanted everyone
to see that before filming was
because that film is so alive
and fleshed out.
The ensemble is so real.
There are no small
characters, no small roles.
Everybody feels so nuanced
that everyone's making choices.
And most of all, they feel
like they went to high school
together.
So I knew we had
to achieve that.
And I said, please, go hang out.
I did send them on playdates.
And I did do everything
I could to convince
them to live together,
and it didn't take much.
As you heard, they
were very into it.
And I really think
the movie feels
good because of their
commitment outside of work,
and that's just something you
can't guarantee as a director.
How do you know
that you can cast
people who will love this
project as much as you?
KATIE SILBERMAN: It also comes
from the top down, though.
Because when your leader is as
open and encouraging and warm
as Olivia was, it sets
a tone where everyone is
able to be as open in response.
And that is what creates,
I think, the camaraderie
and the friendship
and that vibe.
It's like, when that is the tone
that's set from the beginning,
it encourages everyone
else to bring--
not just their A
game and their energy
and their enthusiasm like that,
but also to keep their hearts
open the whole time, which is
a really rare thing on a set
and felt really singular
and special here.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
I think we'll take
our last question.
AUDIENCE: Out of curiosity,
how much of the cast
had actually seen "Fast Times"
before you showed it to them?
OLIVIA WILDE: Many had not.
Had you guys have seen it?
Had you guys seen it?
MASON GOODING: No.
OLIVIA WILDE: You had seen it.
NICO HIRAGA: I'd seen it.
Spicoli was a big--
OLIVIA WILDE: I'm shocked.
[LAUGHTER]
So maybe half and half.
Maybe.
I know a lot of people came
up to me afterwards and said,
I'd ever seen that.
I love that.
And it was real exciting,
because Amy Heckerling
directed that and "Clueless."
So it was fun to tell people,
that great mind brought you
that defining generational
anthem, as well as one
that you maybe saw in the '90s.
How did she do that?
How did she capture the '70s
and the '90s so perfectly?
It's a real skill.
SPEAKER 1: It really does
feel like "Booksmart" could
be that anthem for
this current generation
and what a refreshing,
wonderful, progressive, lovely
take it is.
So it is out on May 24.
Everyone's going to
go see it, right?
Just raise your hand, yes.
100%.
Yes.
OLIVIA WILDE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: So thank you all so,
so very much for being here.
It was such a pleasure.
Big round of applause, please.
BEANIE FELDSTEIN: Thank you.
NICO HIRAGA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]